Marie a 25 ans et elle est l'une des 21
membres de l'équipe du nouveau
café-restaurant café joyeux
situé dans le centre commercial
ouest-fille Parly 2 le café joyeux à
tout d'un café classique sauf qu'ici 80%
des employés sont en situation de
handicap ils sont recrutés sur CV lettre
de motivation et entretien d'embauche
après un mois de stage où ils sont
formés au métier de la restauration les
employés peuvent décrocher un CDI avant
j'étais au chômage pendant 18 mois et
j'ai trouvé un stage au café joyeux j'ai
été polyvalente cuisine ça vice caisse
plonge tout ça d'ici en stage au café
joyeux ici j'arrive à 9h30 qu'à 15h et
là aujourd'hui commande
un travail rigoureux qui nécessite
quelques aménagements pour qu'ils
puissent retrouver une commande sur une
table parce qu'on fait le service à
table on donne un premier cube à un
convive le deuxième cube reste sur notre
plateau ainsi le l'équipier va pouvoir
retrouver la table grâce à ce cube de
couleur un café solidaire et inclusif
qui favorise l'intégration du travail
mais pas que si la joie d'accueil bas de
la joie de la bonne humeur rendre
service
je vais l'aider on voit au bout de 1 2
ans que que en fait il commence à
devenir
très autonome par rapport au transport
ils ont leur carte bleue et certains
meubles du coup prennent leur
appartement ils prennent plaisir à être
dans la société et de pouvoir justement
être au contact de tous les convives
après plusieurs implantations en
centre-ville c'est la première fois
qu'un café joyeux s'établit dans un
centre commercial nous on prend de plus
en plus la diversité et l'inclusivité
auprès de nos visiteurs donc dans
l'ensemble de nos centres en France on a
eu cette opportunité cette belle
opportunité qui a des billets il y a
déjà un petit moment donc plusieurs mois
de travaux et puis qui refuseraient un
tel projet pour prendre un café ou
manger sur le pouce les équipiers joyeux
vous accueillent tous les jours de 10
heures à 20h la totalité des bénéfices
de l'enseigne réinvestis pour créer de
nouveaux cafés dans d'autres villes de
France